hi i'm camino vincent and i'm the
producer at mountains studio based in
Melbourne Australia for me this program
has been very eye opening and seeing how
other countries making games and
collaborating has been really great I
think for me this program is really
important because it does bring very
different teams together and people can
share what they've learned and help
build each other up it's great to see
the support network that's been built
here I would highly recommend to this
accelerated program to indie developers
what you get from something like this is
knowledge that you just can't pick up on
your own or its accelerated you get a
vast amount of information all at once
you get access to other developers you
build a community and as network around
you that you can then lean on and I feel
that's one of the biggest things that we
need in game development is this sharing
the support and this was a program that
really does fast-track that
[Music]